قالت قياده عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه ان
قواتها نفذت 17 اغار على مواقع روسيه من
بينها اربع غارات على مواقع لمنظمات
صاروخيه مضاده للطائرات واكدت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه استمرار القصف
المتبادل على خطوط التماس في زبروجيا كما
تحدثت عن سقوط اكثر من 100 جريح في صفوف
القوات الروسيه جر القصف الاوكرانيه
من اكرامي
ومن دنيا مراسله الجزيره سلام خضر ابدا
معك سلام عن الحديث عن
يعني وقوع ضحايا من المدنيين نتيجه القصف
الذي كان وماذا عن ما يقول الجانب الروسي
بانه التقدم للقوات والقوات الموالي له
همم سلام
عبد القادر نبدا من هنا من مدينه دنيت
اليوم كان صباحا قاسيا على سكان المدينه
هجمات يمكن ان نصفها بالمكثفه استهدفت عدد
من الاحياء السكنيه وهنا وسط مدينه دنيتك
احد هذه الاحياء هو الحي الذي ترونه خلفي
عندما نتحدث عن احياء سكنيه نتحدث عن
مساحه تتراوح بين 30 الى 60 كلم مربع
تقريبا تعرضت لقصف مكثف بصوارخ ادراك بحسب
السلطات المحليه هذا القصف ادى الى سقوط
ضحايا في صفوف المدنيين وطبعا عند تعرض
المدينه للقذف ينعكس الامر على الحياه
بكاملها اليوم لاحظنا ان هناك حركه خفيفه
داخل مدينه دونيت الى حد بعيد حتى
المناطق التي تتعرض للقصف باتت شبه خاليه
من السكان او على الاقل هؤلاء السكان
التزموا بالتحذيرات التي تواجهها السلطات
المحليه وبقى في منازلهم ميدانيا المعارك
ربما الاقصى القريبه من مدينه طونيات
تسيروا او يعني تدور جنوب المدينه القوات
الروسيه تؤكد انها تحاو انها تقوم بصدها
جمات المتكرره تحاول قوه الاوكرانيه الدفع
باتجاه الاقتراب اكثر من المدينه هم
يبعدون الان في اقرب نقطه في تقريبا 10
كيلو مترات عن وسط مدينه دمياط الجيش
الروسي يقول انه يصد باستمرار محاولات
تقدم اوكرانيه اما جنوب فخمه الجيش الروسي
اعلن انه سيطر على خمس مناطق تقريبا لكن
القتال لا يزال يدور حول المدينه مدينه
فخمه لا تزال تحت السيطره الاوكرانيه
اليوم ايضا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن
استهداف اضافي لمن وصفتهم بالمرتزقه
الاجانب يبدو ان هناك احد الادويه التي
تقاتل الى جانب الجيش الاوكراني بحسب
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تتمركز ايضا جنوب
مدينه
يوم قالت وزاره الدفاع ان الطيران همم
العسكري الروسي استهدف على الاقل ثلاثه
مواقع لهذه الكتيبه من منتصفه روسيا
بالمقاتلين الاجانب عبد القادر
عمليات مكثفه من الطرفين وفي مناطق مختلفه
ايضا
عبد القادر ربما طبعا يعني اسخن تلك
المناطق هي بخموطه التي تحدثتم عنها طبعا
بعد سيطره القوات الروسيه على قريه
التي تقع الى الجنوب من مدينه بخمود
المعارك ما زالت مستمره بشكل كبير حديث
ايضا عن سيطره قوات الروسيه على قريه
زيلانو بيلا لكن ايضا مصادر هناك نريد
تحدثنا عنها معها من بخمود من جنوب محمود
تتحدث عن تمكنها من صدق الهجمات الروسيه
حاليا وان القوات روسيه لم تسيطر على خمس
مناطق انما على هاتين المنطقه بمعنى
المدينه التي تم الحديث عنها كثيرا في
الايام السابقه همم كوردي وما يفكا ما
زالت تحت السيطره القوات الاوكرانيه
القوات روسيه تحاول التمدد الشوارع لانها
بتموت لكنها ما زال بعيده وما زالت كما
قالوا لنا بعيده عن همم
حصان او الطوق على مدينه محمود ما زالت
مدينه محمود بامان قالوا بانهم يتحدثون
منذ اشهر عن انه سيطرون عليه لكن حقيقهم
تقدموا عده كيلومترات ووصفوا مدينه محمود
بانها اصبحت بؤره لاستنزاف الجيش الروسي
الذي فقد الكثير من جنوده ومن معداته على
هذا المحور تحديدا مع انهم نعم هي مدينه
مهمه لكنها استراتيجيا ليست بتلك الاهميه
الكبيره التي يمكن ان يضحي بهذا العدد
الكبير من الجنود في هذا الاطار ربما عبد
القادر قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه تحدثت عن
ان هناك عمليات للتعبئه بدات في لوغانس
على سبيل المثال وان هناك تدقيق على
الهويات والسحب للافراد للحاقهم بالجيش
ايضا تحدثت عن عمليه تعبئه جديده في روسيا
نفسها وبان هذه التعبئه ستكون في يناير
وفبراير القادم وان هناك ايضا وحدات
عسكريه سيتم الاصرار في تخريجها في الربع
الاول من العام القادم للحاكم بالجبهه هنا
في المنطقه الشرقيه والحديث طبعا هنا
لقياده اركان القوات الاوكرانيه التي اضغط
على هذه التفاصيل ايضا طبعا تحدثت عن صدها
لتسع محاولات تقدم من جانب القوات الروسيه
على محاور القتال هنا في دونيس وعلى ثلاث
محاولات صدها لثلاث محاولات في لوجاز طبعا
ايضا هناك نقطه ربما في خصوص الجنوب هناك
همم هل تعلم القوات الروسيه تحاول السيطره
والتقدم نحو ارض يفكا القوات الاوكرانيه
تحدثت اليوم عن ان المدفعيه الاوكرانيه
تمكنت من ابعاد القوات الروسيه عن
برفوماسك التي كانت منذ فتره تحاول
السيطره عليها ووصلت الى حدودها الشرقيه
لهذه البلده تقول بانها تمكنت من ابعادها
عن هذه الحدود الشرقيه انسانيه عبد القادر
همم تحدث حاكم قميص عن الوضع الانساني في
من وصفهم مدن المواجهه قال بانه على الرغم
من العمل الجبار على حد وصفي للعمال الذين
يحاولون السعاده في تلك المدن الا ان هو
اعلن ان ان لن نتمكن من استعادتها قصف على
البني التحتيه مستمر يعني طبعا العديد من
المدن سبيرن سوليدار محمود وايضا اوجليدار
كل هذه المدن لن تتمكن السلطات الاوكرانيه
من توصيل الماء والكهرباء والتدفعي اليها
عامر لفي منك سلام خضر من دنيا يوسف شكرا
جزيلا لكم